while fans of the new series anxiously
await
masters of the universe revelation part
2. here's a quick rundown of what the
ending of part 1 means for the heroes
and villains of eternia
and how it might lead into the events of
the second part
sure he-man wears a hairy loincloth and
skeletors a wizard with a skull for a
head but
they're two of the most iconic animated
characters of the 1980s
masters of the universe revelation
treats them with a level of gravitas
that dispels
all silliness while still staying true
to who they are
most surprisingly the series gets rid of
them both by the end of the first
episode surprisingly the pair are both
vaporized when he-man absorbs all the
magic of eternia through the sword of
power to keep it out of skeletor's grasp
it's a typical heroic sacrifice but it's
still a shock to see the series kill off
its most
famous hero within the first episode
however he-man's death
paves the way for tila to be thrust into
the spotlight as she renounces her new
man-at-arm status and goes off in exile
as a mercenary
but tila eventually realizes that she
has a purpose
alongside orko andra and evelyn she
journeys to reunite the two blades that
make up the sword of power and along the
way
she comes to understand that eternia and
all its realms are still worth fighting
for
although tila has to grapple with the
fact that those closest to her lied
about prince adam's muscly he-man
alter-ego
she doesn't let her bitterness get in
the way of restoring magic to eternia
yes she has difficulty working alongside
the likes of eva lynn and beastman but
she knows that it's all for the greater
good
as the sorceress of castle greyskull
reveals tila has to travel to the realms
of subternia and preternia to retrieve
the two different blades that can be
reforged into the sword of power
that's no small feat since saturnia is a
demonic realm home to a bizarre
entity known as scareglow which can
drain any person's life by forcing them
to confront their worst fears
but let's get the most pressing question
out of the way first
is scareglow actually skeletor he does
have a similar skull face purple cape
and armor
after all well the demon has his own
take on the situation calling himself
there's been some debate over whether
scareglow is skeletor's ghost from his
eventual death in the future or
if he's simply a being that skeletor
created that said a toy from 2009
lists scareglow's real name as karak
noor and described him as a former
bounty hunter who was banished from
another dimension
either way scareglow is a formidable foe
and his presence forces tila to confront
her bitterness about suppressing her own
heroic status to live as a normal
citizen after prince adam's death
eventually tila overcomes the illusion
and fights off scareglow by accepting
her strengths
her weaknesses and her fear because they
all make her who she
is giving any part of that up would be
betraying herself
because good and evil are two sides of
the same coin the gate to preternia a
heavenly realm
filled with the souls of fallen heroes
is carved into the walls of subternia
tila evil in andra beastman and roboto
cross over to the other side and arrive
to find none other than prince adam
himself
it's not exactly a happy reunion for
tila because
even though she just faced her own
demons in subternia
she didn't expect to be faced with the
cause of her trust issues
even when prince adam hands over the
pre-turning blade it doesn't
fix things for tila she wasn't able to
mourn the loss of prince adam because he
was hiding a huge
part of his life from her which she sees
as a betrayal but now that teila has
both blades
she and adam reforge it into the sword
of power using roboto's quark particle
collider in his chest
although he already sacrificed himself
to save attorney at the beginning of the
series
prince adam gives up his place in the
paradise to return home and restore
magic to the universe
knowing that he can never return to
preeternia
in a world like eternia a hero always
needs a villain
otherwise he's just a do-gooder with no
real purpose nobody to save and nobody
to fight
to balance the scales of prince adam's
resurrection skeletor also makes a
shocking return at the end of masters of
the universe revelation part 1
impaling the hero with his ram head
staff it's not
the first time audiences have seen the
villain get a one-up on prince adam or
he-man but this feels pretty dire
especially since before this moment
it's explicitly pointed out that if the
titular hero dies again
he won't return back to the pre-turning
in paradise but
how did skeletor make a comeback anyway
in typical villain fashion during
episode 5 of masters of the universe
revelation
skeletor waxes lyrical about sealing
himself inside
evelyn's staff when i was duly destroyed
in the orb
explosion i was forced to seek refuge in
your warm staff to protect my
essence and to add insult to injury
creator kevin smith and the series
writers
give skeletor everything he's ever
wanted
the power of greyskull yeah that's right
it's taken just
under 40 years but the last episode of
revelation part 1
hands the keys over to skeletor and
beefs him up
into a hulking version of himself it's
a huge cliffhanger to leave on it'll be
interesting to see how this huge power
shift will affect the rest of eternia in
part two
especially since reforging the sword was
meant to bring magic back into the world
will all types of sorcery and spells be
warped now that skeletor
has the power only time will tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite animated shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one